وفي ابرازيل تطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا قسم روسي مكثف على مدينه
خرسون ومناطق اخرى في المقاطعه جنوبا
تحدثت السلطات سلطات مدينه ميكولايف عن
قصر روسيه استهدفه منشات البنيه التحتيه
الخاصه بالمياه والكهرباء ما تسبب في
انقطاع المياه عن السكان
جنوبنا ايضا استهدفت المدفعيه الروسيه
مدينه
القذائف وذلك وفقا للجيش الاوكراني على
الجانب الروسي فعلت الدفاعات الجويه في
مدينه ارمز في شبه جزيره القرمه في مقاطعه
دنيا الياس فقد اعلنت السلطات والمواليه
لروسيا سقوط قتلى وجرح وجراءه قصف
الاوكراني في الساعه الماضيه
الينا مراسل الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن
المعتز بالله اطلعنا على اخر المستجدات
الميدانيه التحركات الدبلوماسيه كذلك في
اطار مباحثات وزير خارج البريطانيه
فان هناك
قصفا متبادلا بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه في الجهه المتعلقه بالضفه اليسرى
لنهر دنيبر التطورات الميدانيه وبحسب
رئاسه الاركان هي مستمره ايضا التطورات
الدبلوماسيه هنا في العاصمه كيف مستمره
ايضا ففي زياره هي الثانيه لمسؤولا
بريطاني خلال فتره اسبوع تقريبا وزير
الخارج البريطاني في كياف التقى وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني والتقى ايضا مع الرئيس
الاخراني
خلال هذه الزياره اكد الوزير البريطاني
الوقوف الى جانب اوكرانيا وهي رساله مكرره
من الرسائل التي يؤكد المسؤولون
البريطانيون عليها مع كل زياره تؤكد
بريطانيا على وقوفها الى جانب اوكرانيا
لكن في هذه الزياره هناك حديث عمليات اكثر
على موضوع
المساعدات التي تقدمها اا بريطانيا
لاوكرانيا خصوصا ان الرئيس الاوكراني تحدث
وشكر بريطانيا من خلال وزير خارجيتها على
المساعدات التي قدمتها ال مصادر اعلاميه
بريطانيه كانت تحدثت صباح اليوم عن ان
المساعدات البريطانيه هي عباره عن ثلاثه
ملايين جنيه استرليني تتبرع ايضا المملكه
المتحده بعدد من سيارات الاسعاف وايضا بما
يلزم لاصلاح البنيه التحتيه همم التي
تتضرر خلال ايام الاخيره فيما من الاجراء
القصف المسؤولون الاوكرانيون وفي مقدمتهم
الرئيس الاوكراني شكر وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني على زيارته وقال ان هذه الزياره
تاتي في وقت تشهد فيه اوكرانيا مصاعد في
ما يتعلق بالطاقه نتيجه القصف الروسي وان
هذه الزياره مهمه بالنسبه له اوكرانيا
خصوصا وان همم الحكومه البريطانيه تقدم
المساعدات للجانب الاوكراني وبالتالي هذه
الزياره مهمه كونها ثاني زياره لمسؤول عن
بريطانيا الى
لا لا ايام فقط شكرا جزيلا لك المعتز
بالله حسن مراسلنا من كده